[Music]
Hello friends and Su TV family welcome
once again to I'd like to know our Bible
question and answer program my name is
CA Murray and I'm in the company of
Pastor Steven bour our founder and
president and Pastor David Salazar who
is the director general manager of our
Latino Channel and uh a jack of all
trades here at sutv and uh we are
delighted that you have joined us for
this 30 minute uh Excursion shall we say
Through the Bible through the word of
God thank you for joining us uh as we've
mentioned this is our question and
answer program you send in the questions
we promise to give you the answers from
the word of God if indeed an answer can
be found you can do so by sending your
questions to tvom
tv.org that's
tvss M as in Mary tv.org and we will get
to your questions just as soon as we can
Pastor Salazar would you ask the Lord's
blessing on this particular sitting and
then we'll launch right out into our
questions certainly let us pray our
gracious Heavenly Father we are
delighted that we can come to you at
this hour to seek from you the uh wisdom
and the guidance of the Holy Spirit to
understand your word and to be able to
express and to share and give answers
that will bring the uh Clarity to those
who are seeking for truth I pray that
you will be with us now use us may our
lips pronounce words that will bring
honor to your name and bring people
closer to you we pray this in Jesus name
amen amen our first question comes to us
from Joyce who is from Indonesia thank
you Joyce for giving us your name and
where you are writing from she is Joyce
Issa and Pastor bore informs us that
Issa is Jesus in Arabic is that so
Pastor with two s's yeah with two s's
okay um I've been following your program
from the beginning and all of your
seminars and sermons uh on YouTube so
praise the Lord for for that please CL
clarify whom did the father raise
according to John 5: 21 I always thought
that it was the son who interacted with
Humanity from the beginning it was the
son who spoke to Moses and uh the son
who spoke to Abraham I don't know why it
makes that plain um I cannot find in the
Bible where it says the father raised
anyone um then she quotes uh a passage
from desire VES page 209 Chapter 3 of
paragraph 3 rather in reference to this
verse what it does not necessarily
explain my question so let's Pastor
salaz I'll read John 5:21 and then we'll
take a stab at the answer absolutely
John
5:21 we read for as the father raises
the dead and gives life to them even so
the son gives life to whom he
will you know maybe we ought to read a
little bit more what do you think Pastor
Bo we ought to maybe read down to 20 to
20 read 22 and 23 also yeah we could do
that yes I think we'll bring context to
this yes uh I'm going to read it once
again from 21 to 23 for as the father
raises the dead and gives life to them
even so the son gives life to whom he
will for the father judges no one but
has committed all judgment to the son
that all should honor the son just as
they honor the father he who does not
honor the the son does not honor the
father who sent him all right adding
those several verses does give us a
little context to um what we're trying
to say um particularly the fact that the
father judges no one and that this has
all been committed to to the son Ellen
White makes it plain and she does touch
on this that uh that entity that spoke
to Moses at the Burning Bush was the son
uh The Entity that spoke to Abraham the
son um the salvific process has been
turned over to the son and uh this is
but an explanation of that particular
process anything you want to add Pastor
David yeah in in regards to this
question you know I want to thank Joyce
for sending a question and I like the
fact that she's studying and reading the
Bible and reading Spirit prophecy as
well so important uh it's good to have
individuals who are studying their
scriptures the first thing is that verse
21 you know or or this passage of
scripture it's Christ is giv them an
understanding he's replying to the Jews
who of course did not believe in Jesus
did not believe that he was the son of
God who did not trust even though the
evidences of his ministry of his
teaching of his life provide them with
enough evidence that he was the son of
God I mean there were there were enough
evidence in in his life to show that he
was serving and honoring God and that he
was the Messiah but for them they did
not believe they wanted to reject Christ
and Christ is trying to to let them know
how his life is in complete harmony with
God that he submits his life or his will
to the father and the father loves the
son if you go to verse 20 he says for
the father loves the son and shows him
all things that he himself does and he
will show him Greater Works than these
that you may marble in other words he's
saying the father is the one that has
given me the authority if you will to
perform this to to do these signs and
these wonders it's my submission to the
father because he loves me and I love
him and I submit myself to the father so
he's basically describing this the the
relationship between him and the father
and how it
is in submission to the father that
Christ can do the great the all the
things and even those that have been
raised from the death from the you know
past throughout these scriptures those
have been uh thought an idea an approval
of the father but executed through the
son so it's it's interesting to see that
Jesus is trying to let them know how
exactly the experience for mankind is
the father wants it Jesus performs it
the bottom line is that from eternity
past to during the
Incarnation to Eternity
future Christ has been subject to the
authority of the father maybe I can read
a very key text that speaks about
creation 1 Corinthians chapter 8 and
verse 6 uh 1 Corinthians chapter 8 and
verse 6 it says yet for us there is one
God one God the father there's a comma
there but really it should be continuous
there is one God the
father of whom are all things yes and we
for him and one Lord Jesus Christ
through whom are all things and through
whom we live so everything is of the
father through the son yes uh Ellen
White tells us that Christ uh performed
the will of the father in the creation
of all the hosts of Heaven yes
Colossians chapter 1 makes that clear
that isn't before sin came into the
universe right the father created all of
the angels and the inhabitants of the
world through Christ Christ was the
acted agent and then at creation uh the
father once again creates through the
son uh the Father devises the plan and
the son implements the plan now uh
there's one thing that she says here in
this particular question is
I always thought it was the son who
interacted with Humanity from the
beginning and uh she gives the
impression that uh uh the father doesn't
do any of these things the son does them
uh but but in Galatians chapter 1 we
find someone that uh someone that God
the Father
resurrected notice what Galatians 1 and
verse 1 says Paul Paul an apostle not
from men nor through man but through
Jesus Christ and God the Father who
raised him from the
dead raised who from the dead God the
Father who raised the son from the dead
correct now how do we understand that
did Jesus have uh life Divine Life
within himself to resurrect himself
Jesus has always been subject to his
father yes he could have resurrected
himself yeah but the father resurrected
him what were the last words that Jesus
spoke on the cross father into your
hands into your hands I commend my
spirit he's saying I'm commending my
life to you and uh and then at the
resurrection um I want want us to notice
John chapter 10 and vers 17 and 18 John
10: 17 and 18 uh tells us uh who was it
that resurrected Christ we just read in
Galatians that it was the father who
resurrected Christ but um you want to
read John 10:17 and 18 it says there
therefore my father loves me because I
lay down my life that I may take it
again no one takes it from me but I lay
it down of myself yeah I have power to
lay it down and I have power to take it
again and finishes with this he says
this command I have received from my
father now the word that's translated
power that's not a good translation it's
the word exusia which means authority
authority yeah so Jesus says I have
authority to lay down my life and I have
authority to take it again yeah but why
because the last sentence says this
command I have received from my father
yeah in other words the father
authorized him to resurrect and we know
from Ellen White what happened on
Resurrection morning two angels came
down from heaven one rolled away the
stone the and sat on the stone the other
one stood Before the Throne and said oh
thou Son of God thy father calls thee
yes and then Jesus came forth from the
grave that the life was of with the life
that was within himself Jesus
resurrected with the life that was
within himself but by authorization for
the yes and in First Corinthians 15: 24-
28 it says that when everything are
under Christ's feet Christ himself will
subject himself to his father so that
the father is all in all and selfish
Hearts don't like that because they say
oh so he's G Jesus is going to subject
himself to his father mean he he was the
one who died he was the one who suffered
he needs to claim his rights well that's
exactly the problem with Lucifer exactly
uh for Christ it is a joy to descend and
to
serve that that is the you know
something that unfortunately a lot of
people um you know have a problem with
is understanding our need to submit
ourselves to the Lord and to have that
same experience that we can depend only
on the Lord's leading and not to do our
own will not to do our own you know make
our own decisions per se you know ask
the Lord to guide our lives every day um
and Christ obviously gives that example
as you mentioned Pastor so praise the
Lord for that you know this is a
wonderful wonderful text there is
something that we don't talk about too
much the idea that Christ was in total
subjection to his father everything he
did was in subjection uh to his father
uh because we don't like subjection we
don't like that idea uh it's not
something that but there is this to
Total
cooperation uh between Christ and his
father even till waiting for the call to
self resurrect uh waiting for the call
and you mentioned Colossians I'm I had
flipped over to Colossians uh chapter 1
you pick it up oh I guess around verse
11 and go down to 18 you you see this
formula this recipe for for service uh
you mentioned it Pastor God wants it
Christ performs it you know it's it's
God's Will and Christ performs so you
you have this recipe for the functioning
of god father and God the son in Heaven
and here on Earth and if we could only
be like that to wait on God to hear from
God to respond uh uniring to the voice
of God how much more perfect and
wonderful would our lives in
we could compare it to a
president and a vice president of the
United
States uh is the vice president
inferior as a person to the president no
no they're both people they're both 100%
human right but the vice president takes
commands from the
president so the father is the president
so to speak MH and Christ is subject as
the vice president this is just a figure
of speech Yes the vice president he
takes orders from the father that
doesn't make Jesus inferior he's 100%
God just like a vice president is 100%
human it's just a functional thing yeah
Christ has chosen functionally to be
subject to his father in eternity
past during his
Incarnation now because First
Corinthians chapter uh 10 says 11 verse
three says that the father is the head
of Christ MH and in eternity when all
things are under his feet the son
himself will subject himself to his
father that his father is all in all and
it's no big deal when you're on the same
page sure they are you know they're
they're perfectly aligned uh mentally
physically spiritually anywh you can you
can sort of dissect it they are they are
aligned so when I'm thinking as you do
it is no problem to put myself in
subjecting to you because our minds are
the same our hearts amen amen yeah
praise the Lord great question Joyce
thank you so very much uh we are glad
that you're watching there in Indonesia
maybe we can slip this one in Let's see
we need to go
to let's
see Luke 24 yes Luke 241 in the
Greek uh the Greek word for week is
sabatan which means Sabbath does this
mean the verse should read on the first
Sabbath instead of on the first day of
the week could this be referring to the
Feast of first fruits on the 16th of
Nissan uh instead a Messianic Jew in our
church is using this to argue that Jesus
was not crucified on Friday can you
clarify
this the the thing that pops up at me
when I looked at uh first uh Luke 241
maybe we got to read that rather than
just sort of shoot in the dark pastor I
have it ready it says there Luke
24:1 new King James it says now on the
first day of the week very early in the
morning they and certain other women
with them came to the tomb bringing the
spices which they had
prepared all right um this is from Eric
and we thank
you this brings to mind mhm an
individual who passed away and owned a
chain of radio
stations uh here in the United States
called family radio His Name Was Harold
Camping and he argued that because the
word Sabaton is used here uh first of
the
Sabaton that that referred to Sunday
that Jesus resurrected on Sunday and
that therefore Sunday is sacred because
Luke 24:1 says that Jesus resurrected
first of the Sabbath but really it means
first after the Sabbath there's no doubt
whatsoever that Jesus died on Friday
because the Bible says it was the
preparation when he died yes yeah
furthermore his body saw no corruption
in the
Tomb what would that what does that mean
well the Mana saw no corruption on
Sabbath and Jesus was the
Mana so clearly he was in the grave on
Sabbath mhm which means that if the if
he died on the preparation which the
Bible clearly says and he rested in the
Tomb and his body saw no corruption on
the Sabbath he resurrected the first day
of the week now the reason why people
come up with this idea is because you
know their their um motivation is a good
motivation but it has to be based on
good scholarship of course of course uh
their motivation is if they can convince
people that Jesus resurrected on
Sabbath then the Sunday argument
disappears in other words uh people
can't argue well you know he resurrected
on Sunday you got to keep Sunday as a
new day of rest if you resurrected on
Sabbath that would prove that Jesus is
still uh uh sustaining the Sabbath uh
but but that's not good scholarship the
bottom line is that no reputable Bible
version that I know mhm even hints that
that this in Luke
24:1 is saying that Jesus
resurrected uh on Sabbath uh it simply
doesn't hold water and and you know
another thing is that if you just look
at the verse before in uh Luke 23:56
because you have to make sure that you
know looking even the context it says
there in the last verse of the chapter
23 verse 56 then they return speaking of
the of the woman uh who had come to lay
him the tomb uh then they return and
prepared spices and fragrant oils and
they rested on the Sabbath according to
the
Commandment now on the first day of the
week so we know clearly that they rested
on the seventh day Sabbath and then it
says very early in the morning so it's
telling you as you going through the
sequence as you're going through the
narrative you're realizing that the they
rested as the Commandment on the seventh
day Sabbath then the first day of the
week early on or the first day after the
Sabbath as you will mention you know
early on they came to the tomb so just
by looking at the context you can't you
know just you cannot withdraw this wrong
conclusion uh and I know that the
question that these individual has Eric
is in regards to some Messianic Jew who
is uh using this to argue that Jesus was
not crucified on the Friday but uh I
think that again this is like you said
maybe some they want they want some good
intentions but really wrong premises of
theology yeah I think you know you never
develop a doctrinal premise from one
verse it is good to look at Matthew Mark
Luke and John as they all touch on the
same event um I'm reading Matthew which
is or rather Mark which is a little bit
comes from a different little Angle now
when the Sabbath was passed Mary
Magdalene Mary the mother of James uh
and salomi bought spices that they may
come and anoint him so they Peg it to
the passing of the Sabbath this is the
day immediately beyond beyond the
Sabbath so what you need to do before
you develop your doctrinal pemet put
them all in a blender then you get your
smoothie uh by by synthesizing all four
accounts of the gospel and it becomes a
little bit easy if you take one there's
a slight chance you may stray to the
left or to the right if you don't read
the context in which they all appear
it's really saying the first after the
Sabbath Jesus resurrected the first
after the Sabbath yeah and that's why
all Bible translations since translate
uh first day of the week as the day of
the Resurrection right and that is why
there is no evidence absolutely of of
Sunday being another day of of of of you
know the day where Jesus was U you know
raised or anything like that or or or
Friday in this case like these other
individual is mentioning you know it's
very clear that Sabbath was the day that
he rested in the sepul he was he was
crucified on Friday the preparation day
is is very well mentioned in other parts
of Bible as well as the other part parts
of the gospels and so uh again when you
have uh a verse or a word that may seem
to you know give you a little of a
question just look at the you know at
the context compare scripture with
scripture and you know find out that
there's no other you know indication
that it's such a thing could be it's
truly just a day of and of course those
who argue this several years ago lorine
day MH was a physic
uh in the Adventist Church uh came up
with the idea that Christ the three days
and three nights you have to include
that here because that's that's also
part of P of this argument that uh the
three days and three nights began when
Judas made the agreement with the
Pharisees to betray Christ which would
be Tuesday night so from Tuesday night
to Wednesday night to Thursday night to
Friday night she says that Christ
resurrected after Sundown on Friday in
other words he resurrected on the
Sabbath uh and her whole purpose she
explains is to get rid of the idea that
Sunday we should keep in honor of the
Resurrection but but you have to base
your arguments yeah on good
scholarship and and it there's just too
many texts that contradict that theory
yeah exactly comes from a good place but
it it ends up in the wrong
spot we praise the Lord um that you know
again if as you study these things uh
they make they make sense as you you you
spend time putting the pieces together
here a little they a little bring all
that the Bible has to say on the subject
and then develop your position um and uh
so we we thank you um Eric for your
question continue to study stay strong
in the Lord stay strong in the word and
God will give you the answers that you
seek and we are glad that we can be a
blessing because this this is this idea
of crucifixion Resurrection Sabbath
Sunday and I want to put in a quick
commercial for you because we just came
through a wonderful anchors uh where we
dealt with uh among other things change
of the Sabbath uh from Daniel uh 7:25
and uh the reasons
and machinations behind that that change
uh so we want to put in a quick if you
want to get some good material on this
get the study notes which are online uh
from this year's anchor because uh we
dealt or Pastor bour dealt thoroughly
with with that particular subject and
will be I guarantee you an edifying walk
through 200 and something pages about
254 Pages yeah yeah yeah something to do
on your Friday evenings when you got a
little time Amen to uh to spare again
our time has slipped into eternity allow
me in closing to wish each and every one
of you Grace and peace through our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ we'll see you
again again soon right here I'd like to
know God bless and we'll see you again
soon
[Music]